der nächste Tagesordnungspunkt da geht
es um das Jahressteuergesetz 2022 in
diesem Jahr Steuergesetz sollen auch wie
in anderen Jahren handwerkliche
Änderungen im Steuerrecht vorgenommen
werden wichtige Punkte sollen mehr
Solaranlagen auf Dächern von privaten
Häusern gefördert werden Beiträge zu
Rentenversicherungen sollen bereits ab
dem kommenden Jahr voll von der Steuer
absetzbar sein die Homeoffice Pauschale
in Höhe von 5 € pro Tag soll weiterhin
gewährt werden der Spitzenausgleich für
besonders energieintensive Unternehmen
wird um ein Jahr verlängert der Sparer
Pauschbetrag soll von 8001 auf 1.000
Euro starten
mein Gott und der erste Redner hat jetzt
auch schon das Rednerpult erreicht
Christoph Meyer von FDP
habe dieses Jahres in verschiedenen
Bereichen des Steuerrechts notwendige
ergänzungs- und Verbesserungsbedarf
ergeben diesen Bedarf finden wir jetzt
hier in Entwurf des Jahressteuergesetzes
2022 wieder den wir heute in erster
Lesung beraten eigentlich hätte mein
Kollege Markus Herbrand gerne diese Rede
gehalten er musste sich überraschend in
Selbstisolation bewegen ich möchte die
Gelegenheit nutzen Ihnen zunächst
erstmal einen milden Verlauf zu wünschen
ich glaube die Ampel setzt mit diesen
Entwurf ein Zeichen auch im Steuerrecht
wie wir auf der einen Seite sozial
ausgewogen auf der anderen Seite aber
auch ökonomisch und ökologisch klug
handeln ich möchte Ihnen zunächst einige
Kleinigkeiten nennen die in diesen
Gesetzentwurf jetzt neu geregelt werden
zum ersten der Zuschlag zur Grundrente
wird zukünftig steuerfrei gestellt das
ist für die Betroffenen eine wirklich
großartige Sache wir haben
endlich die Abschreibung in
Mietwohnungsbau von zwei auf drei
Prozent erhöht damit wir die
pauschalitenutzungsdauer im Wohnungsbau
oder bei Wohnimmobilien der Realität
eher anpassen wir haben oder in Fristen
die
homeoffice-pauschale
5 Euro pro Tag maximal 1000 Euro im Jahr
es wird höchste Zeit hier
die Homeoffice Möglichkeiten an die
moderne Arbeitswelt anzupassen
wir werden wir werden die
Absetzbarkeit von Arbeitszimmern endlich
einfacher Regeln ebenfalls durch eine
jahrespauschbetrag von 1.250 Euro wir
werden die zur Vermeidung der
Doppelbesteuerung von Renten den
vollständigen Sonderausgabenabzug von
Altersvorsorgeaufwendungen auf das Jahr
2023 vorziehen auch da kann man
klatschen eigentlich alle klatschen wir
werden den schmarer Pauschbetrag sehr
gut wir werden den Sparer Pauschbetrag
zum ersten ersten 2023 um 200 Euro auf
1000 Euro bzw 2000 Euro für zusammen
veranlagte erhöhen den steuerlichen
ausbildungsfallbetrag erhöhen wir das
heißt ein ganzer Strauß von wichtigen
Entlastungsmaßnahmen der am Ende den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in unserem Land
zugute kommen wird und für uns steht
neben diesem Punkten zweifelsohne der
Abbau von steuerlichen investitionsen
und die Schaffung von gezielten Anreizen
bei der Produktion von Sonnenenergie auf
Wohngebäuden im Fokus wir wollen
Bürokratie abbauen und wir wollen dass
zumindest kleine Betreiber von
PV-Anlagen zukünftig möglichst gar
nichts mehr mit dem Finanzamt zu tun
haben und umgekehrt auch das Finanzamt
möglichst nichts mit dem Betreibern
dieser kleinen Anlagen
und
wenn wir uns vergegenwärtigen wir haben
ja in der Rederunde davor alle über die
Herausforderungen die in den nächsten
Jahren vor uns stehen zusammen
diskutiert dann ist genau der Punkt der
dezentralen Energieversorgung ein
Mosaikstein den wir heben können wo wir
auf der einen Seite einen beträchtliches
Entlastungsvolumen für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger schaffen können und auf der
anderen Seite einen Beitrag zur
Energiesicherheit in Deutschland leisten
können die FDP ist der Auffassung dass
hier sicherlich noch Verbesserungsbedarf
im Laufe der ausschussberatung möglich
ist insgesamt wird in dem
Jahressteuergesetz 2020 sehr viel Gutes
auf den Weg gebracht wir modernisieren
das Steuerrecht wir werden sicherlich
umfangreiche
berichterstatterberatungen dazu haben
insgesamt ist der Entwurf jetzt schon
sehr gut und ich lade alle Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ein diesen Entwurf in den
Ausschussberatungen noch ein Stück weit
besser zu machen ich danke Ihnen
die Mindereinnahmen durch die Maßnahmen
werden im Jahr 2023 auf 3,2 Milliarden
Euro angesetzt im Jahre 2024 auf 3,5
Milliarden Euro Antje Tillmann für die
CDU CSU die finanzpolitische Sprecherin
hat jetzt das Wort liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Zuhörerinnen liebe
Zuhörer Herr Kollege Meyer ihren ihre
Aufforderung diesen Gesetzentwurf im
Laufe des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens besser
zu machen dem kommen wir gerne nach ich
will gerne ja gleich ein paar Vorschläge
dazu bringen aber tatsächlich haben sie
recht dass dieser Entwurf auch schon
eine ganze Reihe positive Entlastung für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger bringt sie haben
genannt den Ausbildungsfreibetrag Sparer
Pauschbetrag zur richtigen Zeit wo
hoffentlich die Zinsen jetzt wieder
steigen Homeoffice pauschale
Steuerfreistellung des
grundrentenzuschlags sind alles
Maßnahmen die wir mittragen können das
ist eine gute Entlastung der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in dieser Situation da werden
wir zustimmen bei der Photovoltaik
brauchten sie ein bisschen Nachhilfe sie
mussten erst unseren Antrag abschreiben
um dann in diesem Gesetz auch hier
der Steuerfreiheit sowohl in der
Ertragssteuer als auch in der
Umsatzsteuer für 30 kW peakanlagen in
der Photovoltaik auszuweiten wir werden
im Laufe des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens
hinterfragen ob es nicht auch für
Solarthermie machen und genau das können
Sie dann gerne wieder abschreiben und
wir werden dieses Gesetz in dem Punkt
auch noch attraktiver machen
bei der Rentenbesteuerung sich zu loben
ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr weit
hergeholt herr Meier denn die
Rentenbesteuerung ist tatsächlich vom
Verfassungsgericht vorgeschrieben dass
sie den
Sonderausgabenabzug vorziehen ist gut
und richtig aber sie alle haben im
Wahlkampf versprochen dass die zweite
Stufe denn die nachgelagerte Besteuerung
später anfangen zu lassen dass die auch
passiert und genau das steht im
Gesetzentwurf nirgendwo sie halten ihre
Versprechen nicht sie beten die Bürger
und dazu kommt dass sie diese 5
Milliarden aus der Rentenbesteuerung
dann auch noch im Entlastungspaket sich
gut schreiben lassen obwohl das mit
Ukraine nur wirklich überhaupt gar
nichts zu tun hat diese
entlastungspakete werden wir nach und
nach hinterfragen
Steuer-ID und das gerade bei der FDP ja
meine dass sie das nicht angesprochen
haben ist klar denn sie verursachen mit
der Kombination von Steuer-ID und
Bankverbindung erhebliche bürokratische
Kosten 13 zusätzliche Stellen erhebliche
Kosten in der Verwaltung und in der
Wirtschaft und tatsächlich behauptet
dieser Gesetzentwurf dass sie damit
demnächst hochwasserhilfen oder Ukraine
oder corona-hilfen auszahlen könnten
nein Sie können nichts davon gar nichts
denn bei keiner dieser Maßnahmen hätten
sie nur die ID und die Bankverbindung
gebraucht sie verursachen Aktionismus
Kosten Bürokratie ohne dass sie wissen
was sie hinterher mit den Kenntnissen
tatsächlich machen wollen wir wollen ein
Gesamtkonzept bevor wir dem zustimmen
wir wollen nicht das Banken zusätzliche
Kosten haben ohne dass wir hinterher ein
Nutzen davon haben ihnen scheint das
egal zu sein Bürokratieabbau ist bei der
FDP offensichtlich nicht auf der
Tagesordnung
auch bei Riester bei Riester machen Sie
einen ersten minimalen kleinen Schritt
es ist richtig dass sie
Zulageberechtigten riestersparhern mehr
Zeit damit geben
kinderbeträge
Kinderzulagen zu beantragen das ist gut
und richtig aber noch besser wäre die
Eltern darauf hinzuweisen dass sie einen
Antrag stellen müssen damit diese
Kinderzulagen nicht verloren gehen und
diesen Antrag zusätzlich zu fordern
werden wir im Gesetzgebungsverfahren
nachjustieren und ich hoffe dass sie
damit machen es ist auch richtig die
zulagenberechtigung erst zu prüfen und
dann die Zulage auszuzahlen auch das
steht im Gesetzentwurf das ist aber wohl
schon längst Fakt das wird schon längst
von den zulagenstellen gemacht was sie
aber nicht tun und das ist gerade bei
der dritten Säule Altersvorsorge nur
zwingen sie kümmern sich nach wie vor
nicht über die um die Attraktivität der
Riester-Verträge 16 Millionen Sparer
müssen seit Jahren mit einer niedrigen
renditeauskommen und sie haben die
Vorschläge von uns seit einer Legislatur
in einer Legislaturperiode auf dem Tisch
und nichts passiert wir könnten sehr
wohl bei der Beitragsgarantie optional
was machen wir könnten bei der
Auswertung der Förderberechtigten was
tun und wir könnten könnten ein
kostenarmes Standardprodukt erstellen
nichts davon tun sie das heißt Riester
wird nicht attraktiver tatsächlich
ziehen sich die meisten Anbieter daraus
zurück sie lassen die kleinen Verdienste
mit der Altersvorsorge alleine auch da
werden wir im Gesetzentwurf nachsteuern
gebäude-
herr Meier leider haben sie uns da nur
die eine Hälfte erzählt ja sie erheben
die AfA von zwei auf drei Prozent aber
jeder Steuerrechtler weiß dass im vier
absatz 2 Satz 3 steht dass man die
Nutzungsdauer des Gebäudes auch
nachweisen kann und diese Passage die
von vielen Investoren genutzt wird die
streichen Sie tatsächlich ist es keine
Verbesserung sondern eine
Schlechterstellung von Investoren bei
Gebäuden und das zu einer Zeit wo wir
energetische Sanierung zwingend
bräuchten auch da geht dieser
Gesetzentwurf nicht frei genug wir
werden im Gesetzgebungsverfahren die
anschaffungsnahen Herstellungskosten mit
15 Prozent hinterfragen und da haben sie
dann eine Chance dieses Gesetz besser zu
machen
Grunderwerbsteuer auch da kleine
Veränderungen die in die richtige
Richtung gehen aber wir alle haben den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern versprochen dass
es bei der Grunderwerbsteuer einen
Freibetrag geben wird für Familien für
den selbstgenutzten
nichts davon wird tatsächlich
fortgeführt wir werden im weiteren
Verfahren viele Änderungsanträge bringen
zum Beispiel auch für Kindergeldzahlung
bei Menschen mit Behinderungen bei
Kinderbetreuungskosten bei der
gendergerechten Behandlung von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wir freuen uns
auf die Diskussionen und fordern Sie
gerne auf unseren Anträgen dann auch
zuzustimmen
das Jahressteuergesetz soll im übrigen
die organisatorische Voraussetzung dafür
schaffen dass der Staat künftig jeden
Bürger und jeder Bürgerin direkte
Leistung auszahlen kann dafür soll die
steuerliche Identifikationsnummer mit
der IBAN also der Bankverbindung
verknüpft werden das dürfte sicherlich
noch einige Diskussionen nach sich
ziehen Michael schrodi für die SPD
jedes Jahr mit kleineren aber auch
größeren Veränderungen im Steuerrecht in
den letzten Jahren hatte dieses
Jahressteuergesetz auch klangvolle Namen
wenn ich erinnere an das Jahr 2019
Gesetz zur weiteren steuerlichen
Förderung der Elektromobilität und zur
Änderung weiterer steuerlicher
Vorschriften mit der Änderung der
Hausleitung heißt für der Jahre
Steuergesetz aber es sind weiterhin sehr
gute Inhalte drin ich würde aber sagen
diesmal können es Gesetz auch heißen
Gesetz zur Umsetzung wichtiger Punkte
aus dem Koalitionsvertrag denn viel was
wir dort versprochen haben liefern wir
jetzt schon insgesamt für das Jahr 2023
3,1
Milliarden Euro Entlastungen für den
BürgerInnen Bürger in der Zeit glaube
ich auch ein guter Beitrag zur
Krisenbewältigung meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
ja wir liefern ich kann mir noch
erinnern wie wir in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen darüber
gesprochen haben wie wir das Thema
Doppelbesteuerung von Renten die es
jetzt noch nicht gibt aber die wir
natürlich auch ausschließen wollen für
die Zukunft angehen können wir haben uns
jetzt darauf vereinbart sogar auf 2023
jetzt vorzuziehen die volle steuerlich
Abzugsfähigkeit der
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge was
zusätzliche
milliardenentlastungen für die Menschen
bedeutet übrigens die nachgelagerte
Besteuerung werden wir genauso angehen
da sind wir noch auf dem Weg das zu tun
wir machen jetzt einen ersten Schritt
wir milliardenschwerden Entlastungen der
nächste wird kommen auch da liefert die
Ampelkoalition
als nächstes
erhöhungsbarer Pauschbetrag auf 1.000
bzw 2000 Euro bei gemeinsam veranlagten
die Erhöhung auch des
ausbildungsfreibetrages aus meiner Sicht
auch etwas was eine wirklich wichtige
Neuerung ist ein Mensch macht ein junger
Mensch macht eine Berufsausbildung was
wir ja wollen er wohnt auswärts er ist
doch kindergeldberechtigt oder die Erde
noch kindergeldberechtigt und diese
Kosten die dadurch verursacht werden
können steuerlich auch geltend gemacht
werden da wird dieser Betrag auch von
924 Euro auf 1200 Euro angehoben auch
dessen Signal wir wollen auch diejenigen
die Berufsausbildung machen die ihren
Kindern auch diesen Weg bieten wollen
ein Stück weit mehr zu entlasten auch
das ein Signal der ampelkollektion das
bei dem Menschen dann ankommt die
homeoffice-pauschale haben wir auch
glaube ich Frau Tillmann in der großen
Koalition eine sehr zeitnah und
unbürokratische Lösung gefunden in
dieser Zeit die wir ver zu tun habe
Koalitionsvertrag wir werden sie
evaluieren
und wir werden nach Möglichkeit sie auch
in Fristen das tun wir jetzt wir tun das
jetzt indem wir sogar auch noch die Höhe
anheben auf
1000 Euro und gehen gleichzeitig die
Frage steuerliche abzugesäuerlichen
Arbeitszimmers an das zu vereinfachen
auch hier liefert die Ampel wir geben
den Menschen die auch zu Hause arbeiten
Sicherheit und auch mehr an Möglichkeit
es sich dafür zu entscheiden zu Hause zu
arbeiten gerade an er sich veränderten
Arbeitswelt auch hier eine Sache die die
Ampel liefert und die versprochen haben
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren als
letztes
und da haben wir durch die Kommission
gaspreisbremse der auch noch mal die
Aktualisierung bekommen und die
Aktualität besser gesagt dieses
Vorhabens mit der gaspreisbremse werden
wir es schaffen Menschen zu entlasten
aber teilweise haben wir auch gesehen
auch in der Pandemie schaffen es nicht
zu zielgenau über das oftmals wollen
weil wir das Instrument nicht haben
jetzt werden wir eine Rechtsgrundlage
schaffen dass wir Direktzahlungen an die
Menschen auf den Weg bringen können dass
wir dieses Instrument der Direktzahlung
auch in Zukunft nutzen können und Frau
Tillmann natürlich wird es dann möglich
sein und das ist dann auch der Wille der
Ampel dass wir das zielgenau machen
machen können Hubertus Haller gesagt es
soll ein soziales klimagilz sein damit
diejenigen profitieren die entsprechend
auch mehr brauchen und diejenigen nicht
bekommen die das nicht brauchen wir
schaffen jetzt die Rechtsgrundlage dass
wir den Fortschritt machen das möglich
zu machen Direktzahlungen auf dem Weg zu
bringen von denen wir gesehen haben sie
sind wichtig wir sie werden wichtig in
die Pandemie gewesen das Ziel genau zu
machen wir wollen das hinbekommen die
Rechtsgrundlage wird jetzt geschaffen
ein weiterer wichtiger Schritt für
zukünftige Herausforderungen die wir
jetzt auf den Weg bringen ich freue mich
auf die weitere Beratung zu diesem
Jahressteuergesetz
nächster Redner für die
afd-fraktion Jörn König
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen Liebe Steuerzahler alle
Jahre wieder ein Jahressteuergesetz so
auch dieses Jahr jedes Jahr wird an ein
paar Stellschrauben gedreht hier ein
bisschen geändert dort ein bisschen
gepflegt es ist und bleibt
Flickschusterei ich will Ihnen auch
sagen warum der Gesetzgeber hat
eigentlich verlässliche und verbindliche
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen und eben
nicht ständig alle möglichen Gesetze zu
verschlimmbessern
das ganze ist jedes Mal ein
Arbeitsbeschaffungsprogramm für
Bürokraten von Ministerium über das
Parlament bis hin zum Steuerberater wann
ging es Belgien wirtschaftlich am besten
als mal 600 Tage keine Regierung
gebildet wurde da hatten die Leute zwei
Jahre lang unverändert stabile Gesetze
und konnten einfach Wirtschaften die
Krönung die Krönung unprofessioneller
und übergriffiger Arbeitsweise erlebten
wir 2019 im Prozess zum Jahre
Steuergesetz 2020 das Gesetz erhielt
damals aus Marketinggründen den Titel
Gesetz zur weiteren steuerlichen
Förderung der Elektromobilität Frau Dr
Giffey mit ihrem gute Kita-Gesetz ließ
damals herzlich grüßen
an einem lauschigen Dienstagabend im
November gegen 21 Uhr erhielten wir 32
Änderungsanträge der damaligen
Regierungskoalition diese 32 anträge
sollten wir dann nach einer Nachtschicht
morgens früh um 9 Uhr im Finanzausschuss
abstimmen eine Missachtung der
oppositionskollegen sondergleichen und
ein Ausdruck der unprofessionellen
Arbeitsweise hier in diesem Parlament
wissen Sie was das schöne an einem
solchen Blindflug von ungeplanten
arbeiten ist dass der Misserfolg völlig
überraschend eintritt
kommen wir zu den Stellschrauben im
Jahre Steuergesetz 2022 es sind
insgesamt 16 Stück ich stelle mal ein
paar exemplarisch heraus erstens die
Homos office-pauschale wird in Fristen
unterhöht das ist positiv viele frei und
Pauschbeträge werden manuell erhöht dies
könnte man zum Beispiel mit einer
Indexierung automatisch und dadurch eben
halt viel besser lösen der Tarif auf
Rädern lässt grüßen den wir schon seit
Ewigkeiten fordern
im Bewertungsgesetz wird die steuerliche
Bewertung von Eigentumswohnungen und
Einfamilienhäusern geändert der
eigentümerverband Haus und Grund
Deutschland schätzt die Erhöhung
zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent ein die
Freibeträge beim Erben werden dadurch
schneller erreicht und dann wird
schneller und höher Erbschaftssteuer
fällig zusammen mit der gerade aktuellen
grundsteuererklärung und einer
Ausarbeitung des wissenschaftlichen
Dienstes des Bundestages mit dem
bezeichnenden Titel Kompetenz des Bundes
zur Erhebung einer einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe in Krisenlagen könnte
man meinen hier wird eine gezielte
Enteignung des Mittelstandes vorbereitet
viertens es soll ein direkter
Zahlungsweg vom Staat zum Bürger für
öffentliche Leistung unter Nutzung der
Steuer-ID geschaffen werden das hört
sich erstmal gut an aber hier werden die
Grundlagen gelegt um große Gruppen des
Volkes dauerhaft von direkten
staatszuwendungen abhängig zu machen
Bürgergeld direkt da Zahlungsweg für
irgendwelche Leistung es scheint immer
weiter in Richtung Umverteilung zu gehen
wie viele Rettungspakete werden davon
ihnen noch kommen die alle die alle von
der fleißigen Mittelschicht bezahlt
werden müssen gehen Sie doch endlich mal
einfach an die Ursachen ran
der Arbeit
der arbeitende netto-steuerzahler egal
ob er Schneider Koslowski oder Öztürk
heißt wird nur noch als maximal
besteuerter geduldeter und demütiger
finanzierungsschärfer behandelt das ist
ein Skandal auch der indigene deutsche
für den arbeitende eine Religion ist und
den die Regierung so liebevoll attermann
Kartoffeln nennt ja diese Kartoffel
fragt sich warum sie überhaupt noch
arbeiten soll
wenn es sich nicht mehr zu arbeiten
lohnt
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
AFD diesem Jahressteuergesetz zustimmen
wird vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Jörn König war das für die AFD der
nächste Redner hier zum
Jahressteuergesetz
2020 Sebastian Schäfer von den
Bündnisgrünen er ist ob man im
Haushaltsausschuss für seine Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren in der akuten Krise wird die
Bundesregierung bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitstellen um für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und unsere
Unternehmen die Folgen der extremen
Preisentwicklungen bei den fossilen
Energien abzufedern
wir nehmen bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro
neue Schulden auf weil in der
Vergangenheit falsche Entscheidungen
getroffen wurden wir können diese nicht
ungeschehen machen und müssen damit
einen Umgang finden
aber diese Koalition betreibt nicht nur
Vergangenheitsbewältigung nicht nur
Krisenpolitik diese Koalition gestaltet
Zukunft und das
und das sehen wir im Jahressteuergesetz
so werden wir ab 2023 für kleinere
Solaranlagen bis 30 Kilowatt
Peakleistung die Umsatzsteuer für
kaufinstallation und Reparatur auf Null
absenken wir haben in diesem Kreis ja
schon gelegentlich über die Umsatzsteuer
und die Komplexität bei den Ausnahmen
gesprochen aber hier geht es darum einen
Investitionsanreiz für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu setzen der
auch volkswirtschaftlich echte Rendite
bringt
Christian Lindner nennt erneuerbare
Energien ja zu Recht freiheitsenergie
gleichzeitig bauen wir damit und das ist
wesentlich bürokratische Hürden ab
vorsteueranmeldungen werden genauso
überflüssig wie die Nutzung der
kleinunternehmerregelungen auch die
Ertragssteuer spielt bei den kleinen
Anlagen keine Rolle mehr das entlastet
bürger:innen und das entlastet dem
Fiskus die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern in den Finanzämtern die
Erzeugung von Bürger in den Strom per
Photovoltaikanlage wird einfacher denn
je
ich möchte mich auch herzlich beim
Bundesminister und seinem Haus bedanken
dass er Vorschläge der Länder
Baden-Württemberg und Hessen ins
Jahressteuergesetz aufgenommen hat
Haushalts- und finanzpolitiker:innen
schimpfen ja gerne mal über die Länder
aber dort sitzt ganz viel
verwaltungsexpertise die wir nutzen
können um Prozesse einfacher zu machen
die fortschrittskoalition nimmt
konstruktive Vorschläge ernst wenn es
nicht nur stumpf heißt muss weg
zuletzt hat die gaspreiskommission die
Idee einer sozialen differenzierten
Direktzahlungen als grundsätzlich guten
Mechanismus bezeichnet mit dem Aufbau
eines direkten austeilungsweges für
öffentliche Leistungen und der Nutzung
der steuerlichen Identifikationsnummer
wird die fortschrittskoalition damit
auch die Grundlagen für ein Klimagerät
auf den Weg bringen
nicht nur für die gaspreisbremse ist ein
solches Instrument eben notwendig wir
brauchen diesen Mechanismus auch um
Preisanstiege zu kompensieren wenn das
notwendig ist und damit die Akzeptanz
des Marktsystems zu erhöhen herzlichen
Dank
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Janine Wissler
ja und die Parteivorsitzende Janine
Wissler hat jetzt für die Linke
[Applaus]
das Wort
im Jahr Steuergesetz
werden neu ger
egelt schade über
abschreibungsregelungen und Freibeträge
und das ist in Teilen auch sinnvoll was
aber bleibt das sind die extremen
Ungerechtigkeiten im Steuersystem und
die möchte ich an dieser Stelle genauer
beleuchten wenn man sich das
Steueraufkommen anschaut dann stellt man
fest dass ein großer Anteil aus Löhnen
und Gehältern also aus Erwerbsarbeit
stammt während leistungsloses Einkommen
und Vermögen in diesem Land kaum
besteuert wird wer nämlich dazu Arbeiten
von den Dividenden seiner geerbten
Aktien lebt der zahlt nach der
sogenannten Abgeltungssteuer pauschal
nur 25 Prozent Steuern egal ob bei drei
Belegschaftsaktien oder die
unternehmensmehrheit im milliardenwert
besetzt und das meine Damen und Herren
ist zutiefst ungerecht
die meisten wirklich reichen Menschen in
Deutschland die über Millionen oder
Übergabe Milliarden Vermögen verfügen
sind nämlich nicht durch Erwerbsarbeit
reich geworden sondern durch
Kapitalerträge und die müssen endlich
angemessen besteuert werden der Anteil
vermögensbezogener Steuern Deutschland
ist verschwindend gering er liegt bei
nicht mal drei Prozent der
Steueraufkommens während die unteren 40%
der Bevölkerung gar keine Ersparnisse
haben oder sogar Schulden verfügen die
oberen zehn Prozent über 40 über zwei
Drittel des gesamten Vermögens höchste
Zeit meine Damen und Herren für die
wiedererhebung der Vermögenssteuer
auch bei den Erbschaften gibt es
ungerechte steuerlöcher die geschlossen
werden müssen zum Beispiel durch so ein
Gesetz es kommt immer wieder vor dass
jemand ein Unternehmen im Wert von 500
Millionen Euro erbt aber dann keinen
cent-erbschaftssteuer bezahlt und die
Steuergesetze werden ja nicht nur
kreativ genutzt und fantasievoll gedehnt
sondern handfester Steuerbetrug wird
systematisch organisiert wir haben die
Woche schon darüber geredet allein im
cum-ex-skandal wurde die Gesellschaft um
mindestens 32 Milliarden Euro betrogen
32 Milliarden Euro die Schulen und
Krankenhäusern gut hätten gebrauchen
können der tatsächlich festgestellte
Steuerbetrug lag im Jahr 2020 bei 1,25
Milliarden Euro zum Vergleich der viel
diskutierte
sozialleistungsbetrug bei 57 Millionen
der Schaden durch Steuerbetrug ist also
22 Mal höher während Menschen die
Grundsicherung beziehen Probleme mit dem
Jobcenter bekommen weil sie Geschenke
von Verwandten bekommen bereichern sich
andere weitgehend ungestört und das hat
auch damit zu tun dass die
Steuerfahndung in Deutschland so
schlecht ausgestattet sind das
regelmäßige Betriebsprüfung überhaupt
nicht möglich sind es ist also nicht das
Sozialsystem dass man es braucht wird es
ist das Steuersystem mit seinen
Schlupflöchern und unentdeckten
steuerhinterzieren und daran ändert
dieses Gesetz leider überhaupt nichts
nicht nur Reichtum vererbt sich auch
Armut wer arm ist kann sich so viel
anstrengen wer will der viel gepriesener
Aufstieg durch Bildung und Arbeit
funktioniert nicht deshalb wäre Armut
bekämpfen will der muss Reichtum
umverteilen durch eine Besteuerung
großer Vermögen und hoher Einkommen das
fordern wir als LINKE das fordert auch
die Initiative ich bin armutsbetroffen
die morgen vorm Kanzleramt demonstriert
denn für Armut meine Damen und Herren
müssen sich nicht die Betroffenen
schämen für Armut muss sich eine Politik
schämen die es zulässt vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
parsamari
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja das
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 mag etwas
technisch daherkommen und es ist in der
Tat ein komplexes Gesetz das haben wir
heute ja schon durch verschiedene
liebevolle Detail Betrachtungen gehört
mit einer Vielzahl von § und
Bestimmungen die wir hier im Steuerrecht
als Ampel angehen und Modernisieren aber
es ist ein echtes fortschrittsgesetz ein
weiterer Baustein um einen Beitrag zu
aktuellen Krisenlage zu leisten aber
auch um den ampelkoalitionsvertrag
weiter erfolgreich umzusetzen da haben
wir einige schon gemeinsam auf den Weg
gebracht in der Steuerpolitik aber
angesichts von ich habe es mir mal genau
angeschaut 115 Einträgen unter dem
Begriff Steuer im ampelkoalitionsvertrag
haben wir noch einiges vor uns und wenn
augenscheinlich der Redner der AFD keine
Lust hat auf eine handlungsfähige
Regierung in dieser Krisenlage in
Deutschland sage ich ihnen wir sind
außerordentlich froh dass wir regieren
wir haben außerordentlich Lust Steuer
damit auch immer gesellschafts- und
Wirtschaftspolitik in diesem Land zu
gestalten meine Damen und Herren
wir vereinfachen mit diesem Gesetz wie
entbürokratisieren wir schaffen
Rechtssicherheit wir helfen mit
steuerlichen Maßnahmen bei der
Energiewende weg von fossilen
Energieträgern wir fördern den
Wohnungsbau und wir entlasten in einer
Zeit von eingetretenen teuren und
sicherlich im nächsten Jahr noch
andauernder Teuerung so wie ich das
letzte Woche hier gesagt habe diese
Koalition bringt Woche für Woche Gesetze
zu Entlastung und zur Stärkung des
Standorts Deutschland auf den Weg diese
Koalition kann Krisenpolitik das haben
wir inzwischen mit mehreren
entlastungspaketen mit einem Volumen von
über 300 Milliarden Euro bewiesen mit
denen wir das Land sicher durch diesen
herbst- und Winter bringen wollen und
wir machen mit diesem Jahressteuergesetz
genau dort weiter wo wir mit dem vierten
corona-steuer hilfegesetz aufgehört
haben für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer zum Beispiel bei der
Förderung von mobilen und digitalen
Arbeiten jetzt in dieser erneuten Corona
herbstwelle besonders wichtig aber auch
weit darüber hinaus ein Megatrend der
von ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmern als
Angebot und genutzt wird ein Viertel
aller Beschäftigten arbeitet bereits im
Homeoffice doppelt so viele wie vor der
Pandemie und ich bin mir ganz sicher
diese Entwicklung wird sich auch in
postpandemischen Zeiten verstärken und
so weitergehen wir wollen als
SPD-Fraktion das Thema Homeoffice
gesamtgesetzlich weiter auf der Agenda
halten wie Sie wissen aber wir wollen es
jetzt mit diesem Gesetz steuerlich
konkret fördern mit einer verbesserten
homeoffice-pauschale mit verbesserten
Regelungen für das sogenannte häusliche
Arbeitszimmer das ist eine
ampelsteuerpolitik die den
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmern nützt
wir sind eine arbeitnehmerkoalition als
Ampel wir helfen den kleinen sparrern
durch die Erhöhung des
sparer-pauschbetrags wir helfen Familien
bei den Kosten für Studium und
Ausbildung durch die Erhöhung des
ausbildungsfreibetrags wir ziehen den
100%igen Sonderausgabenabzug auf 2023
für Altersvorsorgeaufwendungen vor ja
und wenn sie auch recht haben Frau Thema
dieses Gesetz wäre auch ohne zeitenwände
ohne Krisenlage kommen aber es hilft
doch das müssen sie doch auch sagen mit
den größeren kleinen Schrauben die wir
hier drehen um ganz konkrete Inflation
entgegenzuwirken
so das ist jetzt mein zweites Gesetz an
dem ich jetzt Berichterstatter
mitarbeiten darf beim ersten ist es ja
erfolgreich gelungen beim corona-steuer
hilfegesetz ich bin mir sicher dass wir
das druckschulgesetz hier anwenden noch
auf schlaue Ideen kommen und ein gutes
Werk der Bundesregierung noch besser
machen als Parlament vielen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über das
Jahressteuergesetz
2022 und der nächste Redner ist oder
Putin vom Finanzausschuss und er hat
heute Geburtstag und die Präsidentin
gratuliert ihn ganz herzlich
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herzerwärmen
was gibt es schöneres als einem
Geburtstag hier in diesem Hohen Haus zu
seinem wichtigen Gesetz zu sprechen aber
das Jahressteuergesetz
ist wieder Geburtstag da kommt
regelmäßig und ich habe schon viele
jahressteuergesetze mittlerweile gesehen
und darf hier heute sagen der Entwurf
für das Jahr 2022 ist tatsächlich nicht
der schlechteste
er ist einiges an Entlastungen drin für
die Steuerzahler wir haben es vorhin
schon gehört Erhöhung Sparer Freibetrag
Erhöhung Homeoffice pauschale Erhöhung
Ausbildungsfreibetrag und es sind ja
auch Vorschläge die wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode immer wieder gemacht
haben konnten sie aber leider mit einem
Finanzminister Olaf Scholz eben nicht
durchsetzen und deswegen an dieser
Stelle erstmal ein ehrliches Lob auch an
Christa Linda Florian kannst dem
Ausrichten ist ehrlich gemeint das sind
gute Sachen drin
aber wir wären natürlich eine schlechte
Opposition hätten wir nicht auch Kritik
und eigene Verbesserungsvorschläge und
ich muss sagen das Eigenlob das hier
einige der koalitionsredner abgefeiert
haben ist schon stark übertrieben es ist
gut dass ich der Abschreibungssatz bei
Gebäuden im nächsten Jahr von zwei auf
drei Prozent erhöhen soll diese
Forderung hatten wir auch in der Union
schon lange gestellt konnten sie in den
letzten acht Jahren mit dem
Koalitionspartner nie durchsetzen aber
jetzt ist unverständlich warum wir die
Möglichkeit der des Nachweises einer
kürzeren Abschreibungsdauer hier
streichen sollen denn das Antje Tillmann
hat es vorhin schon gesagt ist keine
Erleichterung das bedeutet keine
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sondern es bedeutet dass sie
gerade dort wo die Sanierung jetzt so
wichtig wäre im Altbestand wo wir ja die
co2-treiber haben die Sanierung die
energetische Sanierung erschweren es für
Investoren schwieriger machen dort
vernünftig in die Sanierung zu gehen und
das soll es wirklich noch mal nachdenken
ob diese Streichung in dieser Situation
sind zweiter Punkt riesters wurde vorhin
schon angesprochen sie vertun auch hier
eine Chance bei diesem
Jahressteuergesetz die lange
Niedrigzinsphase und der Kombination mit
der Absenkung des
höchstrechnungszinssatzes jetzt zum
ersten Januar diesen Jahres bedeutet im
Prinzip des faktische aus für viele
geförderte Verträge mit 100%iger
Beitragsgarantie kein Anbieter hat in
diesem Jahr entsprechende Produkte
angeboten und viele Altverträge werden
nicht mehr bedient hier entsteht
sehenden Auges tatsächlich eine
Versorgungslücke bei der geförderten
Altersversorgung bei Geringverdienern
und bei Familien die Lösung wäre einfach
wir könnten die
brutto-beitragsgarantie von 100% auf 80%
zum Beispiel absenken mit diesem
Absenkung wäre sowohl im neu wie auch im
Bestandsgeschäft wieder mehr
Möglichkeiten zur Investition es kann
eine renditeträchtigte Produkt
entwickelt werden bei gleichzähliger
Risikoabsicherung aber diese 100%ige
Beitragsgarantie ist tatsächlich von
gestern der dritte Punkt den wir an
dieser Stelle anzumerken haben von der
Union ist dass die Einführung eines
neuen Umsatzsteuersatzes von 0 bei der
Lieferung von Solarmodulen an private
photovoltaikbetreiber ja
wie soll ich sagen ordnungspolitisch
schon etwas bizarre ist aber es ist
richtig es ist eine gute Möglichkeit zu
Entbürokratisierung der Bürger oder für
die Bürger aber auch hier muss die Ampel
noch mal nachbessern sie haben vergessen
die Klarstellung dass es auch bei mieten
bei Mietkauf bei
Ratenkauf von Solaranlagen hier zu einem
Anwendung des Null Steuersatzes kommen
muss und da müssen sie einfach noch mal
nachbessern und wenn man das dann
anpackt dann sollte man tatsächlich auch
die
Solarthermieanlagen von dieser Regelung
mit umfasst umfassen denn auch diese
Anlagen produzieren ja mit Energie aus
Sonnenstrom die entsprechende Wärme und
deswegen gehören die auch zum Null
Steuersatz wir sind die konstruktive
Oppositionsfraktion ich glaube das hat
heute auch noch mal jeder erkennen
können wir machen konkrete Vorschläge
Verbesserungsvorschläge
wir erwarten gespannt wir ja auch
deswegen natürlich aber wir sind ja auch
sonst immer konstruktiv und wie erwarten
jetzt mit Spannung die Vorschläge auch
des Bundesrates wo ja auch noch mal
einiges aus den Ländern kommen wird und
ich freue mich jedenfalls auf die
weiteren Beratungen auf die Verbesserung
hoffentlich Verbesserung in diesem
Gesetz in diesem Sinne gehen wir es an
Olaf guting heute wird er 52 Jahre alt
und das Hohe Haus hat eben gratuliert
der Applaus allerdings am Schluss kam
nur von seiner eigenen Station Sascha
Müller jetzt ob man im Finanzausschuss
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
erstmals liegt die fortschrittskoalition
ein Jahressteuergesetz vor und setzt
damit im Steuerrecht eine ganze Reihe
von Regelungen um die im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert worden sind
dazu gehört beispielsweise die
Vermeidung der Doppelbesteuerung der
Renten und durch das Vorziehen der
vollständigen steuerlichen Absetzbarkeit
von Aufwendung für die Altersvorsorge
und damit sorgen wir eben auch für
weitere Entlastungen oder auch der
Entfristung der homeoffice-pauschale mit
der wir Veränderungen der
arbeitsweltrechnung tragen
entscheidere entscheidende
Verbesserungen und Erleichterungen
nehmen wir bei der Photovoltaik vor und
sorgen damit für einen weiteren Push für
die Energiewende und vieles andere mehr
das zeigt entgegen anderslautenden auch
hier im Haus mit unter artikulierten
Gerüchten funktioniert die Ampel gut
sie funktioniert wir bringen wir bringen
nicht nur drei entlastungspakete im Wert
von 95 Milliarden Euro und ein
Abwehrschirm von 200 Milliarden Euro auf
den Weg sondern wir sicher nicht nur
unsere Energieversorgung trotz des
Ausbleibens der Gaslieferung aus
Russland wir bekämpfen nicht nur die
Inflation mit gaspreisbremse und
strompreisdeckel und wir arbeiten
gleichzeitig an einer Sicherung sauberen
Energieversorgung auf Basis von
erneuerbaren Energien nein wir
modernisieren auch das Steuerrecht und
bringen mit dem auszahlungsmechanismus
für künftige Entlastung eine kleine
Revolution auf den Weg erstmals
erstmals wird der Staat in die Lage
versetzt Geldzahlungen an alle
BürgerInnen vorzunehmen und das eben
ohne bürokratische Antragsverfahren
mussten wir bei der
energiepreisspauschale noch den Umweg
über die Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber gehen so kann künftig der
Staat etwa ein klimagergeld direkt auf
das mit der Steuer-ID verknüpfte
Bankkonto überweisen ja dieses Vorhaben
ist zunächst ein Kraftakt aber eine
lohnender Kraftakt und wir sollten das
so zügig wie möglich angehen auch die
Länder unterstützend diesen Weg und
haben sich gerade erst noch eine
schnelle Umsetzung gewünscht und das ist
auch unser Wunsch
eine weitere
eine weitere Neuerung ist dass wir die
lineare Abschreibung neuer Gebäude in
diesem Gesetzentwurf von jährlich zwei
Prozent auf 3% anheben es kommt dem
Schaffen neuen Wohnraumes zugute und für
uns Grüne würde es noch besser wenn wir
das auch gezielt mit der Schaffung von
energetisch effizientem Wohnraum
verbinden können sie sehen es gibt eine
ganze Reihe von guten Punkten in diesem
Gesetzentwurf und ich will nicht
ausschließen dass wir nicht noch den ein
oder anderen guten Punkt im weiteren
parlamentarischen Verfahren ergänzen
werden insofern freue ich mich auf die
weitere Erörterung in den
berichterstattergesprächen in der
anstehenden Anhörung und dem Ausschuss
und danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion Tim
Klüssendorf
und Tim kliesendorf ist der letzte
Redner zum Jahressteuergesetz 2022 das
dann weiter verwiesen wird in die
Ausschüsse Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich habe mich ja sehr
gefreut über so viel Kong
Konstruktivität der cdu/csu-fraktion
nachdem wir gestern in der cumex-debatte
doch die ein oder andere
Auseinandersetzung hatten so stelle ich
mir das vorder freue ich mich dass meine
Rede von gestern so schnell Wirkung
erzielt hat vielen Dank dafür ich möchte
heute aber meine Redezeit nutzen um zum
Thema PV noch mal ausführlich zu
sprechen weil das ja doch auf jeden Fall
riesiger Schritt in Richtung weniger
Bürokratie und auch in den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien bedeutet wir haben
uns im Koalitionsvertrag in der
ampelregierung darauf festgelegt dass
wir von 60 Gigawatt auf 200 Gigawatt bis
2030 ausbauen wollen heute das
Jahressteuergesetz ist tatsächlich ein
wesentlicher Schritt dahin wir
entbürokratisieren wir erleichtern und
ich will mal um das deutlich zu machen
einmal kurz darstellen wie eigentlich
der Weg ist wenn ich jetzt eine Familie
habe wenn ich auf mein Einfamilienhaus
eine PV-Anlage setzen will was ich dann
alles zu beachten habe es fängt
natürlich damit an man sich über die
baurechtlichen Vorschriften erkundigen
muss Fördermittel beantragen bewilligen
lassen das sind alles Themen die uns
sozusagen im Steuerprozess gar nichts
angehen anlagenprotokoll vom
Handwerksbetrieb Daten im Netzbetreiber
melden bei der Bundesnetzagentur ins
Markt
stammendatenregister eintragen lassen
die Anlage versichern Zähler anschaffen
ist übrigens gar nicht trivial weil die
Stadtwerke im Moment riesige Probleme
haben die ganzen Zähler zu beschaffen
Netzbetreiber ansprechen wegen der
Einspeisevergütung und bei größeren
Anlagen über 10 kW muss ich auch noch
ein Gewerbe anmelden das ist erstmal der
erste Teil da bin ich noch gar nicht
beim steuerlichen Teil jetzt kommt der
steuerlicher teil und die
Verbraucherzentrale sagt bitte klären
Sie vorher die steuerrechtlichen Themen
weil sie werden sonst auf gar keinen
Fall am Ende zum Erfolg kommen
Umsatzsteuer einfacher Weg
Kleinunternehmerregelung das heißt ich
habe Umsätze weniger als 22.000 Euro im
ersten Jahr 50.000 Euro im Folgejahr das
ist ganz gut weil man ein wenig
Bürokratie hat der Nachteil ist ich kann
die Umsatzsteuer nicht als Vorsteuer
erstatten lassen das heißt die
Anschaffungskosten sind sozusagen höher
hat also ein Anreiz doch Umsatzsteuer an
stellen was passiert aber wenn ich
Umsatzsteuer anmelde ich kann mir
eigentlich ein Büro im Finanzamt
einrichten weil ich monatlich
vorsteueranmeldungen schon als normale
Familie leisten muss bei Nachrüstung mit
batteriespeichern kommt es sogar dazu
dass ich meine Batterie noch mal einzeln
anmelden muss Anlage die normale
solarenergieanlage die Batterieanlage
werden dann noch mal einzeln beim
Finanzamt gemeldet man merkt also okay
das ist schon eine Menge an Bürokratie
ich bin jetzt aber noch nicht bei der
Einkommensteuer die Einkommensteuer
kommt auch noch oben drauf maximal 10 kW
darf ich haben dann ist es Liebhaberei
die durchschnittliche solarenergieanlage
die PV-Anlage hat aber 7 bis 15 7 bis 15
ist natürlich für ein Grenzwert bei 10
relativ ungünstig das heißt auch da eine
große Problematik die wir in diesem
Gesetz aufdecken ohne
Vereinfachungsregelung habe ich also
auch in der Einkommensteuer noch eine
Menge Bürokratie zu erledigen und
deswegen jetzt ganz wichtig was macht
dieses Jahressteuergesetz in den letzten
20 Sekunden Einkommenssteuer wir setzen
den Grenzwert hoch auf 30 kW extrem
wichtig um steuerfrei zu sein und die
Liebhaberei aus Umsatzsteuer wir führen
den notsteuersatz ein sodass die kleine
undunternehmerregelung ohne finanzielle
Nachteile anzuwenden ist und von allen
genutzt werden kann und einen dritten
Punkt noch die Lohnsteuerhilfevereine
dürfen künftig auch beraten das dürfen
sie im Moment jetzt nicht das ist ein
wirklich ganz wesentlicher Schritt der
Entbürokratisierung und ich freue mich
dass wir heute mit diesem Gesetz ein
ganzer Schritt vorangehen
sagt Tim küssendorf Mindereinnahmen für
den Staat in diesem in einem kommenden
Jahr 3,2 Milliarden 3,5 Milliarden im
Jahr 2024 in das Jahressteuergesetz 2022
wird jetzt weiter in den Ausschüssen
beraten bevor es dann hier in 2 und 3
Lesung wieder aufgerufen